[Musica]
c'è una famosa frase di einstein
perlomeno attribuita einstein che dice
che se le api morissero agli uomini non
resterebbero che quattro anni di vita è
un amico apicoltore una volta mi ha
detto che se invece fossero gli uomini a
morire
le api starebbero benissimo le api sono
importantissime per noi sono importanti
perché producono il miele e lo sono
ancora di più perché sono responsabili
dell'impollinazione lo fanno
gratuitamente le api volando da fiera
l'altro appunto impollinano i fiori e
facendo questa attività insieme a tanti
altri insetti che si occupano appunto di
impollinazione permettono l'esistenza
dell'ottanta per cento dei cibi che
l'umanità consumo ogni giorno non solo
frutta e verdura come siamo abituati a
sentire ricordare ma anche latte caffè e
anche la cioccolata in qualche modo è
collegata a gli impollinatori
se quindi scomparissero con loro
scomparirebbero tutti questi cibi
tant'è che il valore del lavoro che le
api tutti i giorni svolgono nel mondo è
stimato in 153 miliardi di euro
e sapete qual è la razza tra le migliaia
che esistono di app e più produttiva e
più famosa al mondo e la pa italiana
l'ape ligustica italiana
ma cos'è che sta succedendo l'uomo e i
cambiamenti climatici che esso in parte
genera stanno mettendo a serio rischio
l'esistenza delle api nel 2017 per
esempio gli stati uniti d'america hanno
perso il 30 per cento della popolazione
mondiale di api oltre a questo si
aggiunge l'abuso l'uso o l'abuso di
prodotti chimici in agricoltura
glifosato e altri strumenti che fanno
morire le api e li disorientano siamo
quindi a un bivio ma non è un bivio
l'apicoltura non è un bivio
l'agricoltura è un bivio l'umanità è la
parte più importante di questa slide è
il massimo uova perché il tempo sta
scadendo sta scadendo perché ci sono
zone del mondo come in queste immagini
in cui le api sono già scomparse sono
zone in cui non c'è più nessuno che si
occupi dell'impollinazione e quindi
hanno trovato un'altra soluzione hanno
usato la risorsa
maggiormente disponibile al minor costo
gli esseri umani che si arrampicano
sugli alberi e con questi spazzolini si
occupano di impollinare da un fiore
all'altro sostituendo le api questo
bivio a due scenari davanti o sostituire
le api con strumenti con nano droni che
qualcuno sta già sviluppando e che siano
resistenti ai pesticidi che uccidono le
api in modo da poter continuare a usarli
senza problemi e non e non soffrire
della mancanza delle api oppure pensare
immaginare un'agricoltura che è
assolutamente possibile che non danneggi
le api e che continua a sfruttarne il
prezioso lavoro di impollinatori
ma perchè vi racconto questa storia ve
la racconto perché il nonno di mio nonno
faceva l'apicoltore e anche il babbo di
mio nonno faceva l'apicoltore e anche
mio nonno faceva l'apicoltore e io avrei
fatto abbastanza volentieri l'apicoltore
ma non ci sono più api e così abbiamo
deciso di fare qualcosa
abbiamo deciso insieme a gabriele che
prima di tutto un amico di unire le
nostre passioni per le api a quella per
la tecnologia
facendo questo abbiamo deciso di fare la
cosa più semplice che sembra scontata
quando si vuole capire qualcuno quando
si vuole risolvere qualcosa cioè
ascoltare ma ascoltare non è semplice
non basta a chiudere la bocca non basta
stare zitti bisogna sincronizzarsi
bisogna mettersi in risonanza
bisogna capire quelli che ascoltiamo
abbiamo iniziato ascoltare le api non è
difficile non è una cosa nuova
gli apicoltori lo fanno da sempre ma gli
apicoltori lo fanno con le loro orecchie
noi abbiamo cercato di farlo in un modo
nuovo con la tecnologia ascoltare le api
è come ascoltare uno stadio dentro un
arnia una casa delle api ci sono circa
50 mila api
oggi è difficile capire cosa dice ognuna
di esse ma sicuramente si riesce a
capire quali sono i discorsi principali
cosa sta succedendo quali sono i
problemi vi ho portato un piccolo audio
così anche voi oggi potrete come
ascoltare le api
questa audio e quello che si sente con
un orecchio normale ci sembra un normale
brusio un apicoltore professionista
potrebbe capire che è un brusio che
indica che c'è qualche problema
la tecnologia gli strumenti con cui noi
lavoriamo e ci aggiungiamo alle armi
tradizionali ci dicono esattamente qual
è il problema ci dicono che questo è un
audio di un'arnia in cui la regina è
morta e quindi le api si stanno
organizzando per crearne una nuova
quindi nutrendo con la pappa reale una
piccola larva per trasformarla invece
chi nun up e normale in un ape regina
quello che facciamo è quindi aggiungere
tecnologie alle arnie normali per
trasformarle in hard né aumentate in
arnie più potenti per fare questo però
appunto per saper ascoltare per
sincronizzarsi con le api
abbiamo dovuto capire e studiare il loro
modo di comportarsi il loro modo di
ragionare
siamo partiti dalla form intelligence è
la scienza che studia gli animali
sociali a picelli e formiche questi
animali sono speciali perché riescono
insieme a fare cose complesse e perché
l'animale non è il singolo animale è
come se l'ape non fosse un singolo
animale ma nelle male e lo sciame che
insieme a dei comportamenti e che
insieme prende decisioni
uno sciame che insieme prende decisioni
più complesse
quindi che necessita di un quoziente
intellettivo superiore a quella di ogni
singola app riescono a ragionare ea
decidere insieme hanno comportamenti e
scelte condivise
questa immagine rappresenta questa cosa
dimostra come le api ragione noi
decidano e si organizzino insieme perché
all'interno del loro sciame a differenza
di quello che siamo abituati a pensare
non sono una struttura piramidale in cui
la regina il capo ma sono una struttura
assolutamente orizzontale in cui ogni
singola app e ha semplicemente funzioni
diverse per il bene comune che è la
sopravvivenza dello shopping sincronia
con l'ambiente quindi questa foto vi
mostra varie le varie app i vari che ci
sono la più grande quella contrassegnata
da un punto e l'ape regina che
all'interno dello sciame come se fosse
l'organo
riproduttore quella al centro un fuoco
che è un maschio che tra l'altro non
punge la semplice funzione di di fare
caldo e gli hanno affidato una cosa
semplice ai maschi e le ultime la più
piccola è una più operaia sono in uno
sciame sono l'ottanta per cento delle
api e durante i loro 50 giorni di vita
assume vari ruoli
all'inizio si occupa di fare il miele
poi si occupa di tenere pulito e nella
parte finale della vita fa il lavoro più
rischioso cioè sala bottinatrici esce a
raccogliere il polline
questi sono alcuni degli strumenti che
utilizziamo che raccolgono dati dalle
arnie tradizionali li portano nei nostri
server dove gli algoritmi li elaborano
quindi lavoriamo con big data e
applichiamo i nostri algoritmi la stessa
swarm intelligence per che ragionino
come ragione uno sciame l'obiettivo è
quello di raccogliere tanti dati dalle
armi tradizionali ma non solo anche
dalle arnie urbane e creare un network
di dati con grandi algoritmi che possa
lavorare sui big data
parlo di arnie urbane perché analizzando
e studiando le api ci siamo resi conto
che nel tempo gli uomini hanno sottratto
spazio le api con città invadenti e poco
accoglienti per quegli animali che li
già vivevano mettere le api in città non
significa importare animali esotici
significa restituire spazio a quegli
animali che li già vivono per fare
questo e per restituire un po di spazio
alle app in città abbiamo pensato e
stiamo provando a realizzare delle arnie
che siano arnie urbane che semplificano
la vita delle api in città e che
semplificano il rapporto e le
interazioni con le api in città per il
bene nostro ed il bene delle api detto
questo torno all'inizio
torno dalla provocazione iniziale aveva
ragione einstein le api l'umanità
scomparirà senza le api o aveva ragione
il mio amico apicoltore dicendo che se
scomparissero gli esseri umani le api
starebbero infinitamente meglio
beh noi crediamo che ci sia una terza
via e a questa via
lavoriamo è la via in cui le aprì gli
uomini si possono gli uomini si possono
aiutare vicendevolmente possono vivere
meglio
juni grazie agli altri grazie e salviamo
le api
[Applauso]